hi this is an introduction to
my patreon page just to show you a small
sample of what you
you would get if you become a
contributor
everything i do it doesn't matter what
you choose whether it's the yoga the
meditation the tai chi
the aikido they're all
going to be broken down into fine detail
i'm hoping there's going to be things
there that even teach us
and beginners can all take something
from it
i've taken from many teachers i'm just
going to hold up this
self-promoting list you may
wish to pause your screen and
scan it sometime these are the teachers
that uh
are better known i've i've had obviously
many many teachers in my life but
they're the teachers
i'm hoping most of you will know
i'm just going to show you a brief one
and i've taken something from all of
those teachers that i've named on there
or else i wouldn't have named them if i
felt they were not significant in my
in my aikido
career i wouldn't have put them on the
list
we all find who we like and sometimes
we don't even tell our teachers who we
like because they may be jealous
you know i'm afraid egotism is a big
thing in the aikido world anyhow
what i want to show you is how i break
things down and
and this should matter to everybody tie
a piece of string to a chair or
something
fixed such as i've done here
put it around your wrist i'm going to
explain shia nagi to you
the way i said and hopefully you'll all
understand doesn't matter how long
you've been doing aikido
you'll understand this they come and
they grab your hand
okay feel this sorry
the art of aikido is the art of
non-resistance it doesn't matter what
style you do
who's who you're following this happens
around the world if you've even been
doing it 20 30 years
this will happen please watch i take
their
list the string is them
i have to keep it talked as it goes over
my head i decide where i stand
and watch where my hands are going now
they're going behind my head
and this sort of thing happens and then
you know you'll end up throwing them
down
the strings gone loose but you've thrown
them down
the way i'm going to break down the
aikido on every technique
may not be with a piece of string but
you can study your techniques at home
cut the gosh the art of non-resistance
means that if i go to them
i become the attacker or that's how i
understand it
that's what the way my brain works
they're coming to me
they're attacking me so why would i
go to them in an error
i would still keep it taught
you notice the hands are in front of my
head i will keep it taught
until it's time to give them back
give them back to their self okay so
my theory is the art of non-resistance
means that
i mustn't resist the firmness of them
and just the technique is strong my
teacher used to say
you don't have to be so
this is then they've got you found me
you you you move the sheer laggy
as it comes here you actually go this
way
you must adjust this way so the hands
are always in front of you
if you look up you should about see your
hands
and you turn and only then
you give them back okay please try
it will cost you a piece of string a
piece of cord
here keep the hands in front of you
i can almost guarantee whoever tries
this
your standard sheer naggy that you do
from a beginner to an
advanced i don't care what level you are
this will more than likely happen
it will not be so that when you look up
you can see your hands
coat the golish many people they do this
and they go
back to back the strings gone loose
and then they throw to me
i am the attacker because i'm going to
them
why can't we think about the art
non-resistance
get out the way please go past i don't
wish to fight
with you you know
please go past i don't wish to fight
with you
you know you may have a few problems
like me with the
robe keep it tall throw the coat of gosh
you know
throw the coat of gosh keeping the rope
tall
these are so this is the detail that
i'll be looking at
fine detail help how do we improve your
techniques
how do we make your techniques more
efficient
stronger but the biggest thing is
let's all do those senses like you know
don't push style to it let's all do us
as aikido
when you get chance to train with
another person
you can do it
as as your string has guided you to
thank you for your time uh i hope you'll
uh be a contributor of my patreon page
and together we can improve our academic
improve our yoga improve our tai chi
meditation and we can fold them all into
one
as oceans he did he done many things
to make his aikido complete
okay thank you for your time